[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
dolone ramsay personality best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety is
my co-host today as we talk to you about
mental health about relationships about
money about life right here on the
ramsay show dustin's going to start us
off this hour in kansas city hi dustin
how are you
good how about you guys better than we
deserve what's up
hey yeah so i haven't done any drastic
decisions um but i know we all hate time
shares and i just kind of wanted to get
your opinion on disney's time shirt
because i know that one's a little
different than the average time sure
it just sucks less
right
hey this is just two guys talking forget
that there's a couple million people
listening what what are you doing man
why are you calling this show
uh well you know i always go to dave for
advice i talked to him a couple months
ago my father-in-law's been trying to
get me to get into dvc
um disney vacation club and you know
i always want to run my thoughts by dave
before i do anything oh you're awesome
yeah yeah okay i appreciate that
absolutely i like that very kind of you
um no i
disney is the best of the worst
but this is not a spectrum i even want
to live on yeah so um if you want to go
to disney it's wonderful just go down
there and rent your hotel and uh you
don't need to be putting your money into
timeshares timeshare is the is a
legalized fraud
uh and you know again the disney plan is
is it is the best plan of all of them
but they all suck this just sucks less
and i appreciate your father-in-law uh
he obviously thinks it's not but he's
wrong
um and my father-in-law has tried to
talk me into doing a couple things too
that i still love my father-in-law but i
didn't do those things yeah
when you say he's pressuring you what
does that what is it like pay me a
picture of that i don't want i don't
want to say he's pressure i mean he's
he's been in since 94 okay and you know
he's gone every year so it's paid out
for him and his opinion um he just you
know the last couple years he's always
brought it up in conversation and my
wife and i've always brought it up in
conversation so
you know we're just sitting here sitting
around talking about it while we're in
disney last week
and yeah you know
thinking
you know okay i actually thought you
called you're making a joke this is a
you're this is a heartfelt call and i
apologize for making a joke i thought
you were playing with us um
yeah
like i'm with dave i think all of our
father-in-laws want the best for us they
have a picture of what the best is and
they and they encourage us either loudly
or subversively but
yeah you got to go with what's right
yeah
my father-in-law's daughter that's
married to me yeah doesn't vote like him
oh yeah
and neither do i has he tried to
convince you of course yes but we we
gave up on that many years ago and we
just decided that we're going to be
friends anyway
even though he's wrong which isn't true
it's just but i have lots of friends
that are wrong so um they vote the wrong
way but um so
you know it's the same kind of thing man
i mean here's the thing the bottom line
of disney or anything else when you're
buying a time share you're buying air
you do not have ownership you're
basically prepaying for a hotel room for
30 years do you have a 10 second what's
the difference between a disney one and
everyone else like why would somebody
say that
disney
is one of the only ones i think it may
be the only one that i've ever actually
witnessed you being able to sell it okay
there's enough of a market for them that
you can actually sell them gotcha you
can't give the other ones away yeah much
less selling you can they're all over
ebay for a dollar you know wow and so
they're they're they you know they they
lose 100 of their value now disney does
not lose 100 of its value but
so you actually have an exit
you actually can sell the thing and exit
if you wanted to
on a disney one and that's
simply because it's disney and they've
just created such a strong market for
their
horrible timeshares right you know but
they're just not as horrible as the
others and the numbers are better i mean
what you pay for what you get and it all
works out better but um especially given
that there's an actual ability that's
probably a market for you to sell it in
later but if you just run the numbers
out and just say okay
i i
very few people
like almost no one does what your
father-in-law has done which goes every
year for three two disney right uh we go
every year somewhere for a lot of years
but very seldom is at the same place you
know over and over it's one of the
problems with buying a vacation home
right is you trap yourself into that
same location again and again and again
and again you better love it you know
and
i just um
i think he's wanting you to live his
dream yeah
and it made him happy and he wants that
for you but that doesn't mean it's a
wise purchase
so good question all right brian is in
baltimore hey brian what's up
how you doing
good man how can we help
oh very good um well i'm a registered
nurse at a small community hospital in
baltimore
and right now the trend is to go agency
to make two three four times as much
money
and i'm really trying to figure out stay
with the
you know
stable reliable job in baltimore or take
the chance and potentially travel
for
more money
what is the downside of traveling for
more money
instability um whether or not you're
single or married
married three kids
okay so time away from family would be a
downside
well it would be the same time either
way
three 12-hour shifts
you don't see them anyway when you're
doing 312's
not really i miss bedtime on the way
home yeah so you would go to
another city do 312s and then have four
days off
potentially there are local contracts
available
okay
so when you say instability i don't see
an end of nursing coming anytime soon
what instability are you afraid of
well with my full-time job i know what
i'm doing from january to december
with the agency world you take 13 week
contracts and you don't know if you have
a job at the end of that 13 weeks
gotcha
have you ever met somebody who didn't
have a job at the end of a contract
yes one of my friends just recently had
her contract terminated okay and then
she was she was able to pick up another
job but it took two weeks to get it okay
yeah okay
well um
unless you you know
okay let me start with this the premise
that i operate on
and it has served me well and i teach it
to other folks to operate on it is
security is not based on your employer
security is based on
your ability to take the skills and
education that you have in the
marketplace and earn a living
your security comes from you not from
your employer it's paycheck is a false
security
and if you've ever run a company and you
had to make payroll you'd know how fast
it is uh because you you know a lot of
these places are scrambling to make
payroll so
in your case your security is based on
the fact that you're in nursing and
there's always been a shortage of
nursing as long as i can remember
and there's always been a place you can
land as long as i can remember so
unless there's a real reason to not take
triple the money i'm going to go take
triple the money for a while give this a
run
and work some 312s and hit some
financial goals
and if that becomes untenable then go
hunt you a quote unquote stable i
wouldn't use the word secure but i would
use the word stable past 13 weeks
regular job but i'm going to give it a
run
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over eight hundred dollars
a year go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsay to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
did
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host this is the
ramsey show
brendan is with us in cleveland ohio hi
brendan how are you
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well i am working on baby step number
two and between my christmas bonus from
work and my two child tax credits and
income taxes coming up i'll have about
16 000
um all at once like within 30 days wow
my question is should i use that to pay
off my car which is my most expensive
debt
because it is 16 000
or pay my two lists i really do but they
also total 600 000 or i'm sorry 16 000
and that would only save me about half
per month so the total of the two levels
that i could pay off with that would be
about two hundred dollars a month where
my car is four hundred and ninety
dollars a month so you have thirty two
thousand dollars in debt you're getting
ready to have sixteen thousand dollars
which do i pay off what is your
household income
um it's hard to say because i get most
of it through travel i work a very
irregular job um
in 2021
90 000. okay all right and so how fast
are you going to pay off 16 000
left over making 90 thousand
um well
it i haven't had the other problem the
other
wrench that gets thrown into it is i go
to school on the side of my gi bill pays
as well so when i start school back up
at the beginning of the year i'll have
more income as well so
um it'll be quicker
i i will have more income and it will be
either way
either way regardless of your two
options you're going to have 16 000 land
there with a 90 000 income how fast are
you going to pay the 16 000.
i mean as soon as it comes in
no honey i mean the second sixteen
thousand
oh um
probably within nine months two years
yeah how about six months
that would be better okay
so
if you're going to pay it off in six
months
it doesn't matter which one you pay off
first
because it's all going to be gone in six
months
and your your question
seems to indicate that the math is going
to cause you to get out of debt faster
and neither set of math is going to
cause you to get out of debt faster
what's going to get you out of debt is
you're leaning in on the debt you make
90 000 a year and you're going to have
only 16 000 left after all this so
you're gonna do it so having said all
that i'm gonna pay off my car last
i'm gonna work through that snowball
smallest largest pay off the first two
and then i want you to pay that car off
by june
i want that 450 a month to haunt you
yeah just let it already touch it let it
just come after you like a neighborhood
dog and drive you crazy
a neighborhood dog
i don't know it's trying to sound tough
i'm not very tough today
man i was trying to flex a little bit
dave's like really
i just most of my neighborhood dogs are
friendly we got rid of the other ones we
live in different neighborhoods dave we
live in different neighborhoods no i
mean yeah the neighborhood i grew up i
wouldn't put up with that stuff nixon
hartford connecticut hey nick how are
you i'm doing well how are both of you
better than we deserve what's up
um so i am 26 um i'm making 60 000 a
year um i really want to go to law
school that's what i've always wanted to
do and with the good school that's in my
city i can just cashflow myself uh in
the evenings
but i do still have um undergraduate
student loan debt up 100 000 and i don't
know timing wise if i should take a few
years to first pay that off
and then do the law school or
do it now and let those go and deferment
and on one hand obviously i want to get
on debt i'd see them in deferment
i set them in deferment cash flow law
school
okay but only if you promise and swear
and whatever other
blood oath you can take that you will
not take out a penny of debt for law
school
oh no no no i went to i'm a finance
degree i work in a hedge fund right now
and uh i know but you have a hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt so
you've done it once i've been kind of
deprogrammed
since then
okay then if you if you can if you will
commit to remaining deprogrammed then
yes the temptation in law school will be
hey why don't you just go ahead and
study once you slow down a little bit
here's some student aid that i've been
there the temptations are real if you
can promise that then knock it out and
be done yeah it's okay to push pause and
finish just don't continue to do harm to
john's point and it wouldn't hurt to go
the other direction a little bit and
start to begin to pay down
while you're in law school while you're
cash flowing but cash flowing law school
debt free is job one job two will start
to reduce the debt
ellen's with us in chicago hi ellen how
are you
doing good how are you dave
better than i deserve merry christmas
merry christmas
i am having a problem
uh 2021 nora 2020 has been very kind to
me
even though we are
just on the edge i hate to say the edge
because it's going to be probably not
another year
um of paying off debt
uh my aunt passed away last month and
she left
me as the beneficiary of one of her
insurance policies
and
when the dust settles i should say once
we get all the paperwork straightened
out and i
get everything it looks like i've got
three thousand dollars coming in
and
the temptation
what i know what i should do everything
should go on our debt that's left
you know it's not gonna pay off the debt
by far but it
it's another three thousand dollars that
we are getting ahead
uh the problem is
there's all these things in my mind
going we know there's this
shiny thing and
i know i have mental issues i know i
have
problems with impulse
this is an ongoing thing i'm
got medical treatment i've
medicine i've got um well i've got that
antidepressant i should say i'm seeing a
counselor weekly on this
um are you married now because
yes i'm married
it sounds like can i can i say something
that's going to be hard to hear
yes john sounds like you're planning for
failure and i want you to plan for
success
and it's easy to plan for failure when
you feel like you have failed yourself
over and over and over again you feel
like that
yeah i can feel this i can hear the
shame through the phone i want you to
let that go and set that down it's
nonsense
you're here and the beautiful thing
about being right here is
you can own what happened in the past
and now you can say
starting today
and if you plan for success you're going
to stumble along the way because you're
practicing a new way of living you're
practicing a new way of thinking you're
practicing a new way of being in a
relationship with yourself and other
people but you're practicing it
and just like lebron james will take a
thousand shots today at practice and
he'll miss a chunk of them just so he
can hit more shots in the game i want
you to practice it i want you to start
by saying i'm gonna put this three
thousand bucks i'm gonna honor my aunt
because i'm the kind of woman who honors
her family members and their stewardship
of their money
i put on debt it's the right place for
it to go and then you may have to set up
a roadblock or two
you may have to make sure it deposits
into an account that you don't have
access to or give up your atm card for a
season
your debit card for a season whatever
that looks like but set up a roadblock
or two for yourself
yeah a good way to do that is get people
you love in your life
and say to your husband
i want you to hold my hand so that i
make it so that i write the check and it
goes to debt
and i want you to walk with me and help
me do this and he can't
he can't say oh no honey it's yours you
do whatever no i need your help i need
you to walk with me and give me the
strength to do the smart thing
yeah yeah exactly
i think you can do it ellen
we've paid off a hundred thousand
dollars so far over a hundred thousand
dollars so far i take back what i just
said i know you can do it
i know you can
yeah you know what else you know what
else indicates that you can
that you called here called here yeah
i mean somebody who couldn't wouldn't
have called here
but you called here you just wanted us
to remind you that you can do it eleanor
it's our job we remind people stuff they
already know that's right ellen i want
you this weekend i want you to get an
hour by yourself for two hours and i
want you to write your anna letter tell
how much you love her and what you're
grateful for
and how much you're going to miss her
and tell her what you're going to do
with that money that money's going to go
to continuing to pay off your debt so
that you and your husband can be free
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two next week on december 22nd
we will do our last live show of the
year
meaning that uh between the 22nd and the
2nd of january you'll get best dubs
which are actually better than when
we're here that's why we call them best
dubs but uh so be sure you tune in but
anyway our our our tradition around here
is on
that last day on this case december 22nd
we do our annual giving show to
encourage generosity to promote a
lifestyle
of generosity to give is better than to
receive the most fun you'll ever have
with money is giving
if you've been the recipient of
outrageous generosity someone gave you
something that changed your life
or you were able to do something for
someone and it just made you cry it was
so fun
i want to hear those stories because
america wants to hear those stories now
i know if you were the giver you feel
like you're not supposed to brag but i
want you to brag because god did it you
didn't do it he just did it through you
shut up we still want to hear your story
but call us and make us cry
so the giving show if you have a giving
or receiving story that is
not 30 left as a tip i'm talking
something
where you just something real happened
okay big
or cool or fun that's kelly she comes
running guess what i did guys guess what
i did yeah give a ten dollar tip we're
like way to go kelly way to go kelly
that's better than uh
all right
so what you do is you go to
ramseysolutions.com
ask ramseysolutions.com
ask put giving in the subject line kelly
will get back to you
and you can share your generosity story
on the giving show on december the 22nd
and we need some good stories you guys
call in with us
right in with those today ramsey
solutions.com ask put giving
in
the subject line martin is in dayton
ohio hi martin how are you
i am fine how are you david better than
i deserve what's up
well i inherited a property not myself
but my wife is the only child of her
parents property we lost one of them in
july of 19 and the second one in
december of 20. wow
we learned that there is a mortgage
against the property and
right now that we were told there's a
moratorium
for the cobalt because my father-in-law
passed away at covent
but we're concerned of trying to take on
the back payments and all that on the
property and how best way to handle it
so you're on
i'm sorry yeah sorry about your loss
thank you hard for your wife how long
have you guys been married yes
over 30 years yeah so there's like your
parents too then
yes yes yeah yeah she uh as far as that
goes uh my mother and father were like
second parents to me they they always
treated me well you know felt loved all
the time no disrespect no nothing we
always just got along we even traveled
together wow whoa
that's cool with my mother-in-law and
her in-laws we would had a massive wreck
out west
on a convention trip that i won but we
won't go into that
okay and they were also home with us so
this house has a lot of emotion in it is
the point
uh
yes uh i don't believe in my wife we
really want to live there we have a home
very similar to it a few blocks away
yeah but just selling it is hard
oh yes yes
mathematically
financially
um
that's what you should do
you should sell it sell it yeah okay and
cause the chances of you having
reverse engineered this and said
hey i want to buy a house that has a
bunch of back payments on it and get in
there and fix it up and rent it
um is about zero you weren't looking for
this it landed in your lap
right
and um
the other thing i'll go ahead and tell
you not mathematically but emotionally
um
it represents the past not the future
and if you want if you want to if you
want something that is
a keepsake it's not a piece of real
estate
okay it's her bible
or a piece of her jewelry or
his old truck even
you know i understand but it's not a
piece of real estate and so your picture
of the future
um doesn't have this house in it uh but
it but but it's also smart to say out
loud
that you're gonna cry when you sell it
oh no doubt no doubt no doubt about that
at all it does need some uh me they've
lived there over 40 years and you know
so i looked at that possibility of
fixing it up and renting it and you know
having the income from that
but i
it's going to be all on me i don't
believe my wife really wants to spend
too much time there right yeah
so backing out of this were you planning
on getting into the
the rental home property business
well
with it being so close yes
before this happened right before it
happened oh before this happened no
because
if what you're trying to do is make the
best of a
of a hard situation right how can i best
honor this memory and here's the thing i
could do with it what i don't want an
inheritance to turn into is a job a
second job for you
that you weren't planning on you know
what i mean
right and if you did the math on the
real estate on the rental property
versus you just selling it how many
months would that of of just cash where
they hand you in a check if you just
said i'm not even gonna fix it up i'm
just gonna go sell this thing as is
and we are gonna
have a neat and neat celebration with
the money in the proceeds we're gonna do
something with that money that's gonna
honor um the the legacy of our of my
in-laws my wife's parents and then we're
gonna go from there
yeah give yourself a little bit of
emotional room but uh
by this time next year that house needs
to be gone yeah
give yourself a little wiggle room you
don't have to rush there's nothing on
fire
um
but but um there's nothing driving this
except at some point they're gonna
foreclose if you don't make up the back
payments but that may that may push you
to do it sooner but um
but i i you know if i'm you i'm going to
go ahead and start my estate sale
planning after the first of the year and
get the thing cleaned out get a swept
out get get in get on
ramseysolutions.com find our real estate
elp have them come over and start
planning it and you know when the grass
gets green let's let's try to get that
thing on the market and take advantage
of this up real estate market and see
what you can do by doing very minimal
work to it as minimal as you can don't
make this your new hobby
but it it is fair to say out loud this
this process is going to be hard
because it's it's
it's a part of the grieving of the loss
of your of her parents
because now there's the loss of the
house and that kind of makes it like
it's a finality to it yeah and it's just
you need it's his personal finance it
goes with the territory so good question
all right micah's in cincinnati hey
micah welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi john how are you guys doing
great man what's up
well so i'm a relatively new listener
and
uh my wife and i on baby step two are
getting out of that debt and
i was wondering i've got a vehicle for
myself and for my wife i actually live
in jamestown i'm like an hour from
cincinnati so it needs to be reliable
and hers as well she's got long travels
too but
um i still owe 10 on my truck and we
have about 20 on her car and i also have
an atv that we owe way too much like 10
grand on
so
i was wondering if it would be worth
downsizing any of those three vehicles
or because they are
doing well for us and they are reliable
and all used um would i be worth just
holding on to at least the car in the
truck or maybe selling the four-wheeler
what's your household income
um base between the two of us is around
150.
and you make more than that what's your
what's your household income
as long as our overtime is open which
covers been screwing up i can probably
come in around 175
okay
well none of this is out of line even
the atv is not out of line but you know
what you do have to do is you're gonna
have to get really serious
about cleaning up 40 000 worth of debt
while you make 175.
this is just financial
laziness do you make that kind of money
and have this debt laying around
am i am i wrong well
we we just got our jobs uh within well a
significant raise we were on my income
of okay 43 000. oh then i'll withdraw
i withdraw my insult
okay that's okay i withdraw my insult so
what i would do is i would say i'm going
to get really really serious as if i had
to buy a 40 000 item to save my child's
life
like i'm going all in here like crazy
totally focused
and i'm gonna knock this debt out really
fast and keep all these items
[Music]
well
a couple of days ago i shared a big
announcement with you guys
and it's almost sold out we are having
a big event here in nashville called
wealth building for 2022
rachel cruz george campbell and i will
be speaking it is a large live event
thursday january the 13th
tickets are on sale and there's about
just a handful left so if you want to go
and you want to learn about wealth
building and building wealth's big hop
topic right now
everybody's trying to figure out how to
be a millionaire everybody's trying to
figure out how to get rich quick
everybody's talking about one thing
building wealth building wealth building
wealth and so we're going to talk with
you about it because and teach you how
to really build wealth
january the 13th here in nashville it's
a one night special event tickets are
just 15 bucks uh you can go to
ramseysolutions.com
events get yours
i would suggest if you're the moment you
hear this that you jump on the website
and do it because you will just have a
few moments left the tickets will
they're just a handful left and they're
going to be gone i'll probably announce
a sellout tomorrow
so um yeah go and get your tickets now
january 13th me rachel cruz george
campbell speaking teaching you on wealth
building for 2022
at ramseysolutions.com
events seth is with us seth's in los
angeles hi seth welcome to the ramsey
show
hi hey how's it going better than i
deserve how can i help
you know let me just first off you know
start by saying that i really appreciate
you know all the information i've been
able to gain um just from watching your
videos from the past couple of weeks and
i've been uh you really do give an
inspiring um
stance when it comes to finances and
stuff and you know as embarrassing as
my situation is or i feel like it is um
i thought that you would be the best
person to help in this regard thank you
basically what what i've been going
through is um and just give you a little
bit of background um i'm the only one
who works in my household um it's me and
my wife newly married uh we just had our
one year anniversary on sunday
and basically what i have is a
auto loan um you know one of our biggest
bills
um that's just causing me a lot of
headache um i've had it you know
previously um before i got engaged and i
got married um and you know as a single
person um this car was you know just
right for me it was something i liked it
was you know i i'll be honest it was a
little bit fancy or at least flashy in
my opinion i
i really do enjoy the car but as of now
being married and a little bit more
mature the the
the car itself um and just everything
that's bringing with it isn't something
that i can maintain anymore so my
question is you know is it
is it a good idea to kind of give the
car up or is that just something i'm
kind of rushing into just as a last
minute option or
i need some information on that kind of
by give it up do you mean a voluntary
repossession
yeah exactly how much do you owe on the
car
uh so as of now i called in and i owed
22 like roughly around 22 000 for the
car have you looked up what it's worth
yeah um i looked up was worth um uh just
recently this weekend we took it over to
a couple of places carmax toyota just a
couple other places just to try to get
um
you know a sense of what people or what
they would give us for the the car um
and so right now the consensus is that
you know 13 000 is you know
the amount that people would give just
because of all the problems it has with
it as a check engine light
um and i mean
you know it's it's an audi so it's a
really nice car but it's luxury and
it's you know the parts are expensive
how old are
24.
okay
um
well the car market is unbelievably hot
right now
uh did you have a car before that you
owed more on than it was worth that you
were upside down and you rolled the
negative equity into this deal
um i did uh but it was under my parents
name um but you rolled negative equity
into this deal
no no no no and with this deal
what year is this car
it said 2015.
okay and would you pay for it
oh
i was a while ago i believe i out the
door it was like 26 to 28 somewhere like
that how do you still look i'm not
buying the 13. the 13 is a bad number
yeah you're getting snookered
yeah
yeah i feel i feel the same way honestly
when i took it to carmax you know they
just said it had because of the engine
light um as a gain or a scratch you know
towards the towards the rear of it as
well and
um you know there are some some
underlying problems with it i guess that
they
had inspected and that's the number that
they came and gave me and from
underlying problems or what
um well so so far from what i know um
when i start the car it starts to you
know stutter and stuff like that and i i
recently had to replace you know what
are you making work on my car
uh i make roughly
i make like 4 100 gross um do you have a
baby
no no why's your wife not work
uh she got hurt a couple years back um
and that's a whole another situation but
basically her
her right shoulder is you know a bit of
a
a bit of a nuisance to her and it's
constantly coming out of the socket
it's a long story but she's basically
unable to
to work her job
well a physical job probably but she
could get a job
oh no 100 and i mean that's that is
something that i because you guys need
money too so okay yeah here's what's
going on okay
um you're looking
and it's human nature and i do it too so
i'm not picking on you but you're
looking for the easy way out and the
voluntary repo is not the easy way out
and 13k is absurd on this car there's
something wrong with this story so what
i would do is take it to a mechanic and
pay to have it fixed and if that costs
you 500 bucks good spend the 500 bucks
get it fixed get the check engine light
off get the stuttering going away then
all you got's a scratch
and then the car suddenly magically
going to be worth 20.
and then you're 2 000 in the hole you go
down the credit union you borrow the 2
thousand dollars and you sell the car
yeah because if they take this car and
sell it they're gonna sell it for eight
thousand dollars on the repo lot and
they're gonna sue you for the difference
in 22 and eight
known as 14.
you lose control of the price when you
give it to them
that it sells for therefore you are
going to dramatically increase the
amount you owe
that you're in the hole
so what i'm trying to do here is to work
you out of this hole
i i mean you might even be able to sell
it for what you owe on it if you fix it
go get it fixed and sell it
but don't give it back to them because
you give it back to them you're gonna
have a 14 000 lawsuit on your hands
where they come after you and sue you
for the difference on this and then
you're gonna be calling me up how do i
settle a deficit on a car repo
and you got a car repo on your credit
and your wife needs to go get a job
so that we've got money to fix all this
stuff
and i want to tell you your entire
disposition it may just be how you roll
through life just kind of low-key guy
as dave said it sounds like you're
looking for
what's the least painful way to get out
of debt like kind of thinking about this
and maybe if i just
you gotta run dude
you gotta say we're done with his life
and we're gonna be finished with it and
okay i can't work on my shoulder i'm
gonna get a job with health insurance so
i can have surgery i'm gonna get a job
selling stuff from home i we're gonna
we're gonna have to fix this thing
and it sounds like you'll have some
marriage challenges just but that's a
whole other conversation you said says
you've got some mental health stuff
going on so physical stuff going it's
all this well you know it's just going
to be this way next month or the month
after that and the month after that
until somebody says no more
seth there's an old book called the
seven habits of highly effective people
that was a perennial best seller it was
a bestseller month after month year
after year after year by stephen covey
the seven habits of highly effective
people
habit number one
they are proactive
they happen two things
instead of things happening to them
and that's what john's describing for
you
that you you need to get in that mode
where i'm going to happen to this car
thing i'm going to happen to these
things there are situ there's things
here you can control
and if you control the controllables
you're gonna end up with a better life
real fast too
yeah like get after it yesterday right
now get after it
light it on fire baby let's let's just
see it burn
not the car
your life
don't burn the car stephen that's not
what i said
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice thank you for joining us america
we're glad you're here
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john deloney
ramsey personality best-selling author
is my co-host it is a free call triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five we'll talk about mental
health
relationships money these are the things
he and i talk about
and sometimes we talk about the thing
that the other one knows something about
april is with us in bismarck north
dakota hi april how are you
i'm good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
okay um i love this show i listen to it
a lot i i drive many hours a week and i
i love your um no-nonsense talk about
money thank you um i am an entrepreneur
and i
have been in business for about 11 years
and
i have no debt no mortgage no car
payment no no student loans anything
like that you're awesome um
yeah
and um my husband and i over the course
of the last you know however long we've
been professionals we have invested
about 850 000
between like rough 401ks
you know various different investment
platforms so you're millionaires where
you go baby step millionaire
i know well and so i have like joined
your your crowd kind of late in the ball
game and i think about how much quicker
we probably could have achieved this had
i been more disciplined with finances
over the years but it's okay you did it
um
yeah
so um i'm kind of at the point so the
whole time has actually stayed at home
with our children for the last um four
years they're all in school now and so i
kind of feel like we're in this like
midlife crisis where
you know we're kind of thinking about
the next step and um i'm in healthcare
and i've you know the way the healthcare
world has gone over the last couple
years and contemplating a career change
and basically my question for you is i'm
like i feel like we've laid this really
great platform
and i don't want to screw it up but i
also feel like taking
you know like chances and risks and like
i thought about do i sell my business
and
i thought about going into a different
type of business um that's more like
family-based and other things that we're
passionate about
um i've kind of been the
career path person for the last
you know 11 years sounds like you can
afford to do it what's your question
so my question is is that like hot
i'm not sure how to make this step as
far as you know like right now you know
we have a generous income and things
like that and um
business valuations like i don't even
know the resources to adapt to any of
these things or like how to make these
steps and changes and
you know
valuing a business that you own now
okay
um like i'm trying to figure out how to
like do the transition like selling
like business selling or hanging on to
something there's like a holder in it i
just don't even know like financially
how to make such a big leap because
you're in such a comfortable position
and then
have you sold it would you why would you
be in an uncomfortable position
well i just said i and like and maybe
i'm asking like do you have resources
when it comes to things like this as far
as like i don't know what you're asking
still yeah
i i think i i i was hoping that you
would just tell me what to do like
well i don't even know what you're i
mean i'll be happy to give you an
opinion because i'm an expert on my
opinion but the um
so you have a business
that you're thinking of selling
yes okay
and you're worried that if you sell it
that you're not gonna be okay but you're
already okay
so how would you be not okay do you
because the income would go away
yeah or i guess like um
you know when
i get like i don't even know who to
contact
in regards to like what type of
financial people guide you through
um
like selling a business uh like who
evaluates your business or how much is
it worth okay i can give you an idea on
how to value it we can work on that for
a minute
and and there are business brokers that
sell it what does your business do
um we're in outpatient rehab okay and
how many employees do you have
nine
none
nine nine nine oh okay
all right and um what was the net profit
of the business the last three years
taxable
um
taxable um
okay so i know like i know growth
revenue off the top of my head and as
far as like what i took home
my draw
i guess would
be what you're asking
i need your profit unless you took all
the profit home is that what you did
no i didn't take all the profit home but
i was just like trying to review my
taxes and like you know how they all
look at the bottom line it looks like
you don't make a lot of money okay um
through like exemptions and things
you may not make a lot of money um
you may own your job
okay so let me help you with this you're
gonna have to go back and do this later
because we're not gonna be able to do it
now here's how you do it
you need to figure out what the net
profit of the business is
period
and if that net profit
includes you having received zero income
and that net profit is your only income
from the business
then you would say
what does it take to hire someone for
this business to do what i do so let's
use an example
let's say you find your net profit is
one hundred thousand dollars
and uh you say i think i could hire a
manager to do what i do for
seventy thousand dollars
that means the net profit after you were
paid your salary
for your market rate for what you do is
thirty thousand dollars
the value of the business is about four
or five times the net profit after all
the employees have been paid including
the person that replaces you
okay so that's the real net profit
because if i'm gonna buy this business
i'm not going to run it and i'm not
going to be working in it and i'm going
to put x number of dollars in it and how
many dollars is it going to give me back
and if i want a 25 return on my
investment it's worth four times that if
i want a 20
return on my investment it's worth five
times that so in our situation there we
have a thirty thousand dollar net profit
in this explanation or our example then
that business would be worth 120 to 150
000
somewhere in there that would be the
value of it
if the business is not profitable and it
owns a bunch of things book value is the
value of closing it and selling off all
of those things
some businesses are worth more that way
than they are trying to sell the profit
because there's not much profit but they
have a bunch of inventory and they own a
bunch of things so you so you close it
and sell it off for book
value but you need to determine all of
those kinds of things and a business
broker can walk you through that and
help you get the business up for sale
you typically will sell it to a supplier
or a competitor someone that's already
familiar with you is your best leads on
selling a small business
if the business only pays you
what it takes to hire a manager it is
not profitable
you made zero
you just own your job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john delaney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five okay christmas
ten days away
wow i got here fast
wouldn't it be good
to get a boost this time of year
that's what our ramsey christmas cash
giveaway is all about
this year's giveaway is almost over this
is your last week to enter
for a chance to win the grand prize of
five thousand dollars no purchase
necessary
gotta be eighteen
ramsey solutions dot com slash giveaway
ramsey solutions dot com
slash giveaway
register
early and often
and for an extra dose of motivation just
in time for the new year we're having
our famous 10 sale and that means you
can shop over 40 of our best-selling
books envelope systems all for just 10
or less
get number one best sellers like the
total money makeover
know yourself know your money
redefining anxiety all ten dollars each
ten dollar books could be your biggest
investment
your best investment
make 2022 your best wealth building year
ever
shop the 10 sale before it ends ramsey
solutions
dot com
chad's with us in minneapolis hi chad
welcome to the ramsey show
thanks for having me on sure
so quick rundown
35
no debt in the world
i've got
and ten thousand dollar rental that's
paid off with a positive cash flow um
i've got 85 grand sitting in a money
market and i'm growing that i'm just
continually adding to that about four
grand a month i'm already maxing out uh
15 into my into raw
so i am currently living rent free in a
house provided by my company um i don't
know if
when if ever that situation is going to
change whether that's going to be 12
months 24 months 5 years 10 years down
the road
but if it ever did end i'd probably
slide down into my paid off
rental
my question is
should i look to do something other than
keeping keeping that 85
grand
that's continuously growing in that
money market or do something else with
it
well
should i should i invest should i put
that you should be invested i mean
beyond beyond your emergency fund it
should be invested in something
um it sounds like a good situation man
you've done a great job yeah um it
sounds like a good situation for you to
just continually save up and buy more
rental property with cash
so when that when that account gets big
enough to buy a rental property go buy
one
right the the biggest thing i get the
biggest thing is is
do i
i ideally i wouldn't want to live in the
rental i mean it's a nice little house
it's very it's very nice but it's pretty
small for for what i would want for
myself and my family sure but
do it and that would be sort of a stop
gap if you know they called me today and
said you need to be out by
friday i'd say oh crap and and move to
the rental because i build in what do
you do for a living they can't do that
but well they could if it's employment
furnished housing
what what are you doing for a living
i work for a mining company so it's it's
a it's a house that just happens to be
on our on our on within our tract of
owned land
and
it's sort of just a fringe benefit of of
me working there but if for some reason
something were to happen to
the company or we we sell off to a
competitor or something like that
someday that's not going to be there but
you'll probably get more than 30 days
notice
it would be right that would be unusual
just as a courtesy but yeah
employee benefit they can call you up
and go hey uh sold the place you need to
move in a month and so then you'd have
to do something and then you'd have to
say all right which of these rental
properties do i want to liquidate let's
say by then you own four of them
and you say okay i'm gonna put two of
them up for sale and we're gonna take
the money from that buys a house
yep and it might take longer in 30 days
so you might be in one of the other
rentals living for a while or in an
apartment for 30 for six months or
something while you you know make the
transition out
if you want to keep it more liquid you
can just go to mutual funds with it and
then you can get the money in four days
out of your mutual funds uh it you know
but you sound like a real estate guy to
me
well no i i i like it you know
in hindsight i wish i would have gone
back over the last 18 months and not
sold some properties that i had just
because of what's happening with the
market but the biggest thing is
am i
if i if i wanted to not live in that you
would sell it and use the money to buy
your house or sell two bucks right and
but
right but with with that 85 is am i
missing out on the market by not having
it
if you want to put it in mutual funds
until you add enough to it to go get
them house another rental house with it
you can that's what i do
and i just use an s p 500 index fund
because there's no commissions on it
and if you if it stays in there longer
than a year
uh you're you're when you do pull it out
whatever gains you've got to be on
capital gains rate at 15 not on ordinary
income so that's what i do i throw extra
cash in a
uh
in an s p 500 until i've got enough to
buy another piece of real estate
okay and that but i'm more real estate
than i am mutual funds i've got a lot of
both but i got more real estate
and so um i just use it that way and
that way i don't have it just sitting
and checking which just makes me sick
right i mean i don't i need you need to
get it working for you but an
interesting situation and by the way you
have done a really really good job
absolutely
i i've i've lived in several of those
situations where like just as dean of
students gotta be at the school in the
middle of the night and so that the
your position comes with
um on particular provided housing or
it's a house adjacent to the community
and sometimes it's a year let's start
here but i've always circled back and
said hey we've done this for 12 months
for 24 months
can i get a year lease here can we do
this at some sort of so i have a
guarantee and y'all have a guarantee and
they've done it every time doesn't sneak
up on you right so it may be worth going
back and just say you know i need this
in writing that i got this a year at a
time yeah and every you know that's not
a bad idea it would give you a little
more stability than stability and them
just walking in the middle of the night
and going oh we sold the mine
right
right remember that time mom and daddy
lost the house when they sold the mine
you know yeah you don't want that all
right let's see here emmanuel is with us
in odessa texas hey manuel how are you
hi how are you today great man what's up
so i had a question i wanted to get your
thoughts on a whole life insurance i've
got a term life oh
don't do it don't do it damn it so i've
got a term life insurance for my family
and i my wife and three kids actually
just two of them on the on the term life
um anyway they paid about 111 bucks a
month
and it's time for me to transition i'm
eligible to transition some of them to
whole life no
so the numbers they gave me were like
pretty scary right two hundred dollars
and it's like they the benefit of it
that i'm really looking for they are the
borrowing feature but that's not until
about seven or eight years down the line
of this fight
let's just stop for a second
yeah okay so
whole life did you notice it's 20 times
more expensive
it's super expensive yes it's 20 times
more money i didn't figure that out it's
a nickel on the dollar
so for a nickel you can buy as much term
insurance as the dollar cost you it's 20
to 20x
so that other 95 cents is going into a
savings account called cash value so
when you borrow money that you put into
a savings account do you all do you
often borrow your own money
i have never
and pay them interest to borrow your own
money is that nice of you i know that's
what i'm trying to figure out yeah well
don't figure it out run
uh go get
get term insurance call
zanderinsurance.com
get a quote from them get the proper
amount of term insurance it's 120th is
expensive never do investing with life
insurance people always do investing
with investing people
yeah don't buy your mufflers at the
break shop and put your own cash in an
account and borrow from yourself for no
interest
that's the nicest thing you can do for
you
i like me so i'm going to borrow my own
money and pay my self interest
what a scam that is pay them interest to
borrow your money after you it is a scam
we're going to take your money we're
going to make they're so slick that they
make it sound sophisticated yeah well
this is a great product because after
you've had all these years you will be
able to borrow your cash value out from
your salary it's tax-free
by the way
100 of borrowed money is tax-free
anywhere you borrow money it's tax-free
like this is some kind of sophisticated
but something you guys should be ashamed
of yourself it's awful
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the ramsey solutions lobby on the
debt free stage george and sharon are
with us hey guys how are you better than
we deserve i love it look at you two in
unison well merry christmas to you where
do you live we live in statham georgia
which is uh eight miles
west of uh athens georgia
uga country beautiful country
beautiful mountains huh no no no no
you're down at the foot of the mountains
okay yeah we're well down the foot of
mountains okay all right i got confused
but i know where you are all right
generally so welcome so how much debt
have you paid off 62 000 very good and
how long did that take about two and a
half years good for you and your range
of income during that time uh
during
2020 it was a running about 94 000 and
then in 2020
it was i mean 2021 it was running uh
about 91 000. okay cool what do y'all do
for a living
well i'm retired
i retired three weeks ago hey
congratulations what did you do for a
living well
for 20 years i did lawn service okay and
then i contracted throat cancer which
meant i had to give up my business
because i spent a year
trying to stay alive what'd you retire
from
um well the loan business no okay no
actually uh my daughter works at a
dealership in duluth georgia and she got
me a job as a lowly lowly porter
i thought he says that that's great but
uh sharon what do you do i'm office
manager for the georgia department of
natural resources awesomeness very cool
what kind of debt was the 62 000 well 48
000 was the house
she had two credit cards with 8 000.
excuse me i had one with 3 000
and then we had a dental emergency which
threw in another 3 000. all right so all
together we came out to 62 000. and you
paid off the house and everything
everything i'm looking at weird people
yeah we i'm sorry we didn't do uh the
baby step two properly we we went ahead
and paid the house the whole thing just
knock it out while we're at it well you
didn't know a lot on it so that's good
what's the house worth uh right now
about 225. way to go you guys how's it
feel to have no payments in the whole
world it feels wonderful and i'm
thrilled to be here and i'm thrilled to
be retired
[Laughter]
oh my goodness so what started this
journey two and a half three years ago
that made you say we're gonna get out of
debt well five years ago she got the
book
you know uh money makeover
but
she didn't quite get into it then and i
i wasn't aware of it that much at that
point
then while i was recuperating from my
throat cancer i was watching youtube
and you're on youtube i've heard that
yeah
uh and i started listening and thinking
well you know we can do something like
that if i ever get a job
and finally i did get a job and then we
started working on having the the first
step done we had our thousand dollars
which came in handy a number of times
um
but then
in the around september of 2019
we said let's really do this because we
need to retire and sharon's insurance
says finally
well every day
every day at work i brought my lunch and
i would sit in my office and turn you on
on youtube and i'd listen to you and i'd
listen to these debt-free screens and i
could just feel the freedom in it and
i'm thinking
we're going to do this this is my dream
i love it so who who finally had the
courage to sit down across from the
other one and say it's time let's do
this well actually it was pretty much
mutual yeah
i started pretty much trying to get rid
of the credit card debt that i had
incurred
and then she started getting on board
seeing that we were by the way i got to
say the uh
the steps
the small one
then the next then the next
that's so encouraging
once you get that first one paid off
it's it's like
wow
we did it
and then we started throwing money at
the second one wow we and then it just
went right into the house how long have
you all been married eight years eight
years way to go and the first time
you've been debt-free i assumed during
the eight years yes i've already gone
through two bankruptcies in my life
my goodness
well you guys are incredible i'm so
proud of you and we're so thankful for
you we wouldn't have learned all this
but we listened to you and we learned a
lot from you well we're very we're
honored you're why we're here where you
guys are heroes you took control of your
life and uh and enabled george to retire
that's good
i'm gonna retire this coming year good
good you should i started when i was 16
so whoa well it's time yeah
yeah you got a little you got a little
built up there so what do you say to
somebody who says
i'm too old
i i it's too late for me it's too late
for me
it's i'm just this the way this is
you're never too old we started in our
old age
but um i wished i had known earlier so i
could have become a millionaire but you
know i i trust god and i know he could
do anything amen amen
hey i don't i don't doubt you're gonna
be millionaires yet we might i don't
doubt it a bit so well congratulations
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is now that you paid
off 62 000 house and everything in two
and a half years oh you said it yourself
never give up
start with the smallest debt
pay it off go to the next one pay it off
in the next one and you just get so
encouraged yeah yeah but we also
encourage them to
to reach out and
and have jesus get into their hearts sir
amen amen
well done you guys
very well done well we've got a copy of
the book baby steps millionaires for you
that's our next that's our prescription
for you that's the next
chapter in your story uh the book comes
out january the 11th but you're gonna
get a an advanced copy in just a few
minutes when we take our commercial
break here also give you a copy of the
total money makeover you can give away
to somebody and get their journey
started you guys are an inspiration
you're inspiring people you're heroes
thank you so much for being who you are
and for sharing your story well thank
you dave
it wouldn't have been possible oh i
didn't do it you did it
so uh
who was your biggest encourager outside
the two of you
actually just the two of us the two of
us so you didn't talk you didn't have
anybody like in your corner out there
yelling well they just looked at us we
said something they just
you know they kind of looked at you like
you lost your mind yeah but now your
house is paid for yes you know a payment
in the world
vehicles are paid for we have a old
camper it's paid for i love it hey
george i before we do this the deaf we
scream you said something and it rang
the true from your
from your heart
you've been through two bankruptcies
you've fought and survived cancer the
phrase never gives up means something
special to you doesn't it yes it does
actually uh
last year no this year i got diagnosed
with prostate cancer
and it was diagnosed early enough that
compared to my throat cancer it was a
cakewalk to get treated never give up
never give up never give up thanks for
sharing that brother
that's that's a that's an inspiration
for me personally thank you it's
important you know don't quit don't quit
don't quit don't quit love it love it
love it george and sharon athens georgia
62 dollars paid off in two and a half
years making 94-91
house and everything a hundred percent
debt-free they're weird count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
we're debt-free
oh fun
i love it
how cool are they man very well done
they're very cool
they're very cool they might be the
coolest people we have watching youtube
i assure you they are yeah yeah because
there's some 19 year olds watching
youtube they're nowhere near as cool as
george no they don't even know what cool
is like georgia knows
that's pretty cool and sharon for sure
they're rocking this they're rocking
this it's beautiful that's fabulous man
the number of people in our current
society in our current culture who run
up against something hard and just throw
their hands up and say
i quit
somebody bail me out somebody because i
is too hard and then to see someone like
george never quit never quit just keep
getting back up man so what's my answer
to throat cancer as soon as i get well
i'm getting a job and get out of debt
that's right
so i can retire
and i'm retiring ding ding this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five zak is
in las vegas hey zach welcome to the
ramsey show
hey thanks dude god bless
god bless you sir what's up
better than i deserve how can i
yeah so the my
easy
straightforward question is
should i continue to fax out my 401k
should i
not do that and use the disposable
income to save her down payment for a
home which i kind of already have almost
or dedicate 100
of all of my earned income to paying off
my debt
so
the context is
i'm 37 years old uh my salary
employed salary is 75 000. i have 26 000
in credit card debt
13 000 of that debt is 0 until may 2022
and 7 500 of it is zero percent until
november of 2022.
i have a 420
25 a month car payment but that's zero
percent
i'm renting
um
and that's about it
how much do you have in savings
about eight thousand eight thousand
and how much do you owe on your car
23 give or take okay 23 000 okay
all right
well lucas here's the thing
maxing out your 401k being debt free and
buying a house are all three
excellent goals
but you know how you eat an elephant you
know how you eat an elephant a bite at a
time
if you try to do three things at once
none of them are going to get done
so years ago doing what i do i started
coaching people and i started doing
myself
to say i've got to focus
all of my efforts on one thing and then
the next thing and then the next thing
and that focus allowed me to actually
accomplish the goals rather than dilute
my efforts by
spreading them so thin that nothing got
done
and we call that process that now
millions of families have gone through
the baby steps
sure baby step one
is a thousand dollars
baby step two is to become debt free
everything but the house
three is save an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
after you have that done is when you
would save the down payment for a house
and then you would start baby step four
which is 15 of your income going into
retirement
uh you sir have a major debt mess
and because it's all zero percent you
think it's intelligent it's not you have
made a mess
you owe 50 000
on crap
and you don't even know what all of it
is
but you're all walking around like it's
zero percent and that doesn't matter a
bit you have a mess
so what you've got to do is take seven
of your eight thousand dollars apply it
to your smallest seven thousand dollars
worth of credit cards because those will
be your smallest debts
list all of your debts smallest to
largest pay minimum payments on
everything but the little one attack the
little one with a vengeance work your
way through these debts as fast as you
can probably going to take you 18 months
to two years and then you're going to
build your emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses so if you had
twenty thousand dollars setting in a
bank account and no payments at all and
started saving for your house down
payment you would be wise
sure yeah i've already in the past
since april of 2019
i've paid off 26 000.
and i mean i you know i do i did take
your your course way back my parents
kind of put me through it and uh you
know i was zero credit card debt i had
zero debt period you know like 800
credits for everything but i was in my
late 20s and you know i was looking
around at my elders
who
you know
had good 401ks and great money but they
worked at a company for 20 years so when
i had relatively
zero responsibilities i
you know did the risky thing and went
pursued my dreams and
and i'll never regret it because you
know god definitely built my character
as a man that's the man i am today but
now i do have this mess and so
i i know that the debt snowball but
i guess i kind of wanted
just a little bit more feedback on your
your perspective uh regarding it sounded
like you wanted to be an exception
that you're a special guy
that your debt was a little bit
different because it was zero percent
and you have the harder idea
that didn't make you a man yeah
yeah no no that's that you know but it's
it's more of like
so if i'm maxing out my 401k my
as i am now like i'm i'm putting 25 of
my paycheck in
and
my discretionary income after my
expenses every month is 600.
and so i have that to play with if i
stop contributing to my 401k except for
four percent which is the company match
what do you what do you do for a living
i'm an architectural photographer okay
is that zach you're you're broke and
deeply in debt yeah you're broke brother
this is what your plan brought you to
and so i wouldn't use your plan anymore
your plan sucks yeah you're broke man
you need a new plan and our plan is
proven and it works you can choose you
get to do that you're 37 and you're a
man you can decide what you want to do
but you called here to ask what we would
tell you to do
and um
the law of gravity is the law of gravity
find a proven
process and attach yourself to it it's
called in business best practices
we find out something that's working and
we emulate it copy it steal the idea
whatever you want to call it and i want
you to steal these ideas i want you to
work this baby steps exactly
as you were taught in financial peace
university
and um
and you know if you want to do something
else that's fine but you called here
yeah it i want to
press on him a second he was trying to
make this a math problem
and i think one of the fundamental
misses sometimes it is ultimately a math
problem
is that it's a psychology issue too and
there should be some discomfort i want
you to get out of this thing
and it's like well it's a hundred
dollars here and we can then you wake up
and you're 37 and you're making a great
salary and you have negative nothing to
show for it right there's a lot of
photographers who don't make 75 000. you
must be good at what he does
but he can't see the forest for the
trees here man yeah you're trying to
here's the thing
you can't fix stupid with math
and personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge the stuff
that make people
the principles and the processes that
makes people wealthy are very simple to
understand but they involve controlling
yourself we just heard in the last debt
free screen
paying off that smallest one gave us
some momentum to get the next one they
gave us a yeah it's about setting your
insides on fire and i think you said it
like brother you're you're broke
you're broke you're 50 000
man
and you make 75 i mean that's not a good
ratio no
that should scare you yeah instead of
going well it's zero percent and seventy
five hundred zero percent seventy
percent may have twenty two shut up
you're broke and if an architect firm is
gonna have to do layoffs
before they start cutting the principal
architects they're gonna cut the
patrol salary photographer that makes 25
grand
the security you think you have isn't so
secure brother
be debt-free man yeah yeah it's it's
it's worth it so but this is a
decision-making process that people have
to go through and
and so um
you know
it's
years ago i hired a trainer to come to
my house and you know try to get the
belly off of me again and try to try to
do something try to get myself in shape
and um
and it would be like i go down there
i've got a keg he's got a six-pack
right
and he goes well this is what you need
to do
and i go well you know i kind of think i
have this other plan
and he goes he
sits your butt in the floor and do sit
up shut up but uh okay so i can see your
body but
but listen i have this other idea i mean
you know it's like yeah you're gonna
have to quit eating 73 donuts
yeah well i think i can do the donuts as
long as i do the workout how about you
slow down trainer
[Laughter]
and then i found the you know the whole
thing is the nutrition's almost the
whole stinking thing you cannot run a
big mac you cannot run enough miles
that's right my gosh
decide who you're gonna listen to uh the
guy with the keg or the guy with a
six-pack
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
bologna i almost said it deloney i did
say it it came out of my mouth okay this
is my last day on the show well it's um
why are you that you're that sensitive
you're gonna quit no i've i've we've
been worried that you're senile and it's
happening
it's happening
hey who says you can't be the leader if
you're senile
i see what you did there too well done
well done hey listen my name rhymes with
the process lunch meat is a rough
childhood thanks for bringing it up dave
i don't know well it's what drove you to
be a counselor our weaknesses are
what
what
it's what made you a man my son rave
damsy and john bologna here to take your
calls there you go
it's going downhill and we haven't even
gotten the phone number triple eight
eight two five five two two five merry
christmas america we're glad you're here
apparently we're not but we're going to
answer your questions anyway lucas is
here in tri-cities washington hi lucas
how are you
how you doing dave john
hey uh i got a question for you need
your advice
my family's grown and my wife she's
looking for a bigger house
and we currently own three
uh ones paid off we have about 200 000
between the other two
and so i'm just looking for some advice
and direction on whether keeping
property selling one or
i don't know
that's what i'm calling so
you you want to do
you want to sell one why
well i don't want to sell one i need a
bigger one my family's uh outgrown the
one that we're in oh i see yeah
you said your wife wants one do you want
one too
yeah happy wife happy life so uh well
okay yeah we're ready all right so we're
moving up in house
your current residence will sell for how
much
uh right now around 300 and the house
you're gonna buy would cost how much
well
uh if she gets her way probably six
six fifty
you know somewhere in that price at some
point we have to make a wise decision
together rather than just making a
princess happy so
what are we gonna do here let's be a
grown man and a grown woman what price
range of home are we actually going to
buy
uh let's go on the high side 6.50 all
right so you need 350 000 more than your
house
yes where are we going to get that
um
that's that's kind of what i'm i'm
looking for advice on uh do you have 350
000
in an investment that is not retirement
uh
almost yes that we own a house and it's
paid off and it's worth about 325.
okay so would you rather sell it
and your personal residence or sell your
investments and your personal residence
to pay cash for 650.
those are your two choices
well
i guess
sell on the the paid off one that's what
the wife wants to do
and
you know the market where we're at as
far as renting
you know
we our initial idea was to have a house
for each one of our kids for school
and then you know when they get old
enough that's going to pay for the
school but
right now i don't know if that's
possible with wanting a bigger house so
i guess
selling selling the one that's paid off
square feet do you live in
about
17 150
how many kids do you have
i have three what ages
uh one three and seven
okay
here you have a zoo yeah you're in it
now yeah you are in it to win
okay so yeah yeah a little more space
would make a little more sanity i agree
with
that um yeah and see i have uh what are
you making here
um i'm around 100 000.
does she work outside the home
she does
okay all right
so i wanna i want you to reframe this
conversation i don't like the way the
conversation is being answered every
time i ask a question okay i don't
either for the sake of your for the sake
of your relationship and your sanity
okay
proverb says who can find a virtuous
wife
a virtuous wife
for her worth is far above rubies the
heart of her husband safely trusts her
and he will have
no lack
of
gain
so there is tremendous wisdom
in your wife as a grown woman
not as a princess with a red face
stamping her foot that she wants
something
but your wife is a grown woman and you
connecting and saying
we
decided
that with a 100 000 income and three
littles
we want to move to a
575 000 house
that is our budget we are not going to
go over that we are going to liquidate
our home and the investments to pay cash
for that that leaves us with one rental
home which means our next goal will be
to buy two more rental homes because we
had a goal of one rental home per kid to
pay for their college or something like
that that we together develop a plan
that gives our family a better standard
of living square footage wise but is not
you responding to well my wife wants to
sell this my wife wants to do this and
my wife wants to do that i'm getting
tired of hearing what your wife wants
exactly take ownership
sure i understand
yeah she she just started working as a
as a teacher as well so
sure
she's she's got a an income pretty close
to mine as well that's awesome so you
got a 200 000 your income you can
accomplish some of these goals but my
point is not that her opinion doesn't
matter it's that it does matter and so
does yours and you don't have the you
don't get the privilege of blaming her
for these decisions you don't agree with
and you go along with or worse you do
want to do these things it just sounds
cool to like be with a couple of dudes
at the water cooler talking about the
old ladies that are getting no man we
want to get a bigger house
well so she wants to sell i don't
i
i want to look into where because
there's a age gap between us i want to
be able to retire when i can retire
and and
the cost is you live in 1700 square feet
with three littles and it's driving her
by nuts
that's the cost you got to change your
picture brother you had it you had an
awesome goal and then life threw
something at you and now it's time to
change your change goals yeah what
you're just
200 000 household income paying cash for
a 575 000 house is not a bad place to be
it's better than most yeah and still
owning another and still owning another
rental that's paid for and you have no
payments in the freaking world at that
point and you guys can pile up some cash
and buy some other rentals and do some
other stuff uh so yeah it's just a
different picture so you're you're that
nothing's ever gonna work out exactly
like we always thought it was going to
when we were 20. yeah because we didn't
understand stuff we weren't 20. oh when
we were 30 oh when we were 40. oh when
you're 60 right nothing ever comes
exactly like you think it's going to but
you have to learn to navigate this
together and use the wisdom
two opposites attract and larry burkett
used to say if if uh if op is a good
thing opposites attract because if you
weren't opposite one of you be
unnecessary
so you need each other to complete the
picture of wisdom
and lean in on that
[Music]
so
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
monday i shared a big announcement with
you guys we have a huge event on
thursday january the 13th here in
nashville called well building wealth in
2022.
tickets are almost gone we started
selling monday they're almost sold out
and uh we're gonna have a thousand plus
people there they're almost gone
building wealth is the hot topic right
now everybody wants to be a millionaire
too many people trying to get rich quick
nothing down real estate all the stuff
is going on out there
everybody's talking about building
wealth and guess what we know how
so we're going to teach you how some of
you have done this some of you are baby
steps millionaires some of you are on
your way some of you are confused some
of you are in financial peace university
some of you have a crazy brother
oh that's all of you
and some of you need to get started and
you're going to miss out go january the
13th here in nashville join us for a one
night special event rachel cruz george
campbell dave ramsey building wealth in
2022 whole 15 dollars for tickets
there's just a handful left
probably my last announcement before i
announce a sellout right now
dot com slash events to get your tickets
it's game on january 13th let's kick
this 2022 thing out let's get it going
our question of the day is from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and new promos all
the time always use the magic word the
promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal today's question comes
from kirk in virginia
kirk says my wife says we
can
that's not really a complete sentence my
wife says we enjoy we
feel we can enjoy things in life such as
taking our son to disney world because
she knows
my wife says we can't enjoy things in
life such as taking our son to disney
world because she knows i'll be grumpy
about it later or bring up how much
money it cost
we're on baby step 3 and have no debt
except for mortgage and about 60 grand
in savings how do i try and not be so
anxious about spending the money we have
i hate seeing the number disappear from
our accounts but don't want my life to
feel like we can't enjoy
milestones dave can i tell you something
i struggle with this too
i wrestle with this
um
man i had a hard conversation with my
son recently about this same thing
uh
you've you've been working with couples
for 30 years man
how what have you seen when it comes to
this
well i mean it's living in scarcity it's
a it's a but it's a saver mentality not
a spender mentality yeah
he enjoys saving money more and he
enjoys spending it yeah
and um the spender enjoys the experience
enjoy spending it more than they enjoy
saving it yeah and uh a balanced mature
approach is is that we have the ability
to do both
and get joy from them but we just know
our default our natural
tendency is to move towards one of the
other i'm a spender yeah so by nature
it's not hard for me to move even today
to enjoy money but the only way i enjoy
money now
is knowing that i've got i've done my
work over here um
it's like i had to um
you know i i i had to get my homework
done before i could go out to play you
know kind of thing and uh but in the old
days i just went out to play and the
homework didn't get done that's called
immaturity and so you spend money you
don't and you don't know anything saved
so then the opposite of that is this
person who's a little bit more scarcity
savers generally or more scarcity versus
abundance spenders have a tendency to be
more abundance versus scarcity it's not
always true but it's pretty much
rachel's book know yourself know your
money she goes into a lot of this stuff
but um the uh uh
i mean for me i think you just saying it
out loud right there is a big thing it's
huge that that kind of starts to set you
free
and you go okay
why is it i'm saving money there you go
is it only for security
no
your intellect will tell you that's not
the only reason now your emotions might
tell you that's the only reason but i'm
saving money so that yeah it comes down
to so that's for what yeah right yeah
and so
and and
we all know in our intellect
some of us are more emotional about it
than others but we all know in our
intellect that you that that
four-year-old when you blink they'll be
14.
so you better do disney while you can
yeah you don't get a second go-round on
that puppy
because you can now now you don't get to
go use that same line as an excuse to go
into credit card debt to go to disney
because you're broke and you're out of
control no you got you owe that kid
stability at home so you got to do your
work first do your homework for you got
to play but now you got your homework
done yeah don't sit there and read a
book go out and play
you know and and so you've got to force
yourself to do that and
part of it is
if you have if you look at the money and
you say the money that's left after we
do this is more than enough
it's we're fine yeah
and that's kind of the facts or your
friends you know almost your trauma
stuff where you guys deal with trauma
and you say well you know i'm afraid
the emotions are making the decision
and
facts are my friends i got plenty of
money i got money yeah so i can do both
and i'm okay
yeah notify yourself that you're okay
james clear writes about um changing
habits and and
i love the way he framed it i've never
heard it framed this way which is if you
want to change your habits the best way
to do that long term is to change your
identity first
and this is an identity
call out that his wife makes here that
it's almost not worth doing things as a
family because of who you're gonna be
later
yeah and as a as a dad this rings true
my wife calls it sunday afternoon dad
she's like it just kind of becomes
everybody just back up a little bit
because dad's starting to he's tired
from getting up at church and he's ready
for work tomorrow i don't want to be
that i don't i want to be like i would
rather my kids when they're 18 remember
man remember sunday afternoons were such
chaos and fun and we never knew what was
going to happen because dad was bonkers
versus you don't get around dad so this
to me starts with i don't want to be
known as the grumpy dad every time we
did something joyful with money with
money because that says you've that says
to my kids i value the money more than i
do time with them that's right
and if i'm pouting about it if i'm
pouting about it if i'm being ugly about
it if i am rolling my eyes that my wife
and kids want to have joy in their life
and so i think i want to say okay i'm
going to be the dad who loves spending
time with my family and let's reverse
engineer that what's the money going to
be that it's going to take for us to go
on these vacations and feel safe yeah i
love that here's the thing you do for
people you love
your kids your spouse
sometimes you do stuff they want to do
a lot of times you do yes and you're not
a twerp about it yes
find joy and them having joy yeah i mean
i there's stuff there's a lot of stuff i
mean i
i like people but i don't like social
settings at all right
at all
but my wife
completely eats that stuff with a spoon
but this idea of standing around with a
drink in your hand and you go what do
you do shoot me oh god i just would
rather be
i'd rather be in the basement you know
reorganizing the dirt i mean something
god almighty but but you know so but but
i had to to make it this a conscious
decision to not be in constant eye roll
mode
and just go this is something gives her
life yeah
and so i'm gonna go and not steal her
joy
every time we go to a party and then in
return
i found out i don't have to go to all
the parties right right i get i get i
get payback for it but i didn't even
know that was coming but yeah i had to
make that decision relationally yeah and
i still kind of as you can tell
frequently have to remake that decision
but but when you get a new corvette i
bet you say sure and you'll go for a
ride and she goes sure dave i'd love to
and she grits her teeth through the ride
you know i mean i think that's part i
think it's part of being a a great
husband a great spouse a great parent is
leaning in and part of the joy being no
i must hank and i went hunting this
weekend i would have had a better
outcome
had i been not with a 10 year old in the
woods or 11 year old because they're
known for how quiet how quiet they are
but i wouldn't have traded that weekend
for anything yeah right
we'll talk about this weekend it was
pretty chaotic we'll talk about that for
the rest of our lives and so it's making
those types of trades
and in this situation
kirk you got the money bro the good news
was like kirk is he's so self-aware oh
yeah he asked the question his wife
didn't write this he wrote it yes great
great man start with identity i want to
be a dad
who loves being with my kids and my wife
and i love having fun with them yeah now
what does that look what i have to do to
make that identity happen and i'm going
to allocate a portion of the money that
i know is going to make me a little bit
uncomfortable and i'm going to overcome
that discomfort to still have joy
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
dot
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage erica
is with us hi erica how are you hi dave
good how are you welcome i'm better than
i deserve where do you live i live in
fowler california what's that near
fresno oh yeah good okay beautiful area
welcome to nashville and all the way
over here to do a debt-free scream
that's right that's my purpose for being
here i love it how much have you paid
off i paid off two hundred and ninety
thousand dollars total including my
house wow
look at you
i love it you're so hungry and ninety
thousand dollars 290. how long did this
take ten and a half years whoa
long time fan and your range of income
during that time i started at 70 000
went up to 90 and sometimes a hundred
wow what do you do for a living i'm a
dental hygienist i started fresh out of
my career wow
and just got after it how much of the
290 was the house well i was a few years
into my career uh 200 was the house and
90 000 was college debt car debt credit
cards and personal loans that i borrowed
for my divorce girl you're a superhero
thanks this is pretty amazing thank you
ten and a half years
as you're saying these things out loud
it like your body is you haven't taken a
breath in ten years no i haven't my
family hasn't seen me like rest and i
haven't taken a breath and i've been
this go
person for that long
i can feel your body being like and
we're done right here on the jeffree
state this is like a nice end of that
chapter and that long journey i've been
on wow wow yeah so what happened 10
years ago
there was a local church offering dave
ramsey classes it was 12 weeks at that
time i believe
and my friend asked me to join he was
leading the group and i said i didn't
need it and he said well you have debt
don't you and i said yeah but i can pay
all my monthly bills and he said i think
you joined the class and i refused a
couple times and then i finally decided
to do it to be a friend and curious to
see what it was about
completely transformed my life from that
point oh my gosh mm-hmm
and his name is joel rivera hi joel
joel
joel
i love it very cool
that's amazing so you went through
financial peace university and you went
game on
but you begin the process how were you
able to stick with it for ten and a half
years i you know when i followed it
exactly like you said i went through
each step the baby step one emergency
fund paying off everything smallest to
largest debts i know people like you say
want to do interest higher interest
first no smallest to largest those those
little
rewards along the way just kept me going
and um
i just i had timelines and i had goals
and i could just like envision like what
would it be like like could i really do
this it was almost
unreal and i just kept the closer i got
i kept thinking i i think i can do this
and
um my son was a big supporter my parents
were my big cheerleaders there my rock
my son is 23 now so he grew up with a
budget and 3.99 pizza nights take and
bake and we did a lot of
pack your own lunch and bring your own
lawn chair go to the farmer's market and
that was our free friday night we just
were very creative and we had a lot of
fun went on hikes and we just we did it
was a good life even though we were on a
budget it was tough but it was very
rewarding
way to go thanks it's incredible and i
picked up extra jobs i was working
saturdays i was working six days a week
for over 10 years and occasionally i was
working on sundays there was
surprisingly an office that had
scheduled some sunday patients and
i just did whatever i could do to just
keep making more money they needed me to
work an extra hour or two of overtime
sure
i did it and you just pushed through
what's this house worth it's worth um
270 thousand dollars phenomenal yeah
it's a town home and it's i love it yeah
it's all yours oh my no matter what
happens no one can take my house away no
one can take my car away if something
happens to me those those are there to
stay it's
it's a secure feeling i can't even
i can't even like grasp it
that's so good that's so good how much
have you built up in your retirement
accounts
so my retirement account is two hundred
thousand dollars
[Laughter]
and then i have a roth ira that i need
to start putting into aside from that
and then and then the house yeah and
then i got my fully funded emergency
fund yeah you're gonna be a millionaire
in 20 minutes girl yeah you are on your
way yeah absolutely amazing
wow you are special this is so cool so
there's lots of parents that i talk to
that
lament the fact that they don't have
enough money for all these fancy shiny
gadgets and toys whatever
you raised kids
by going on hikes and going to play and
spending time together what's your
relationship like to your kid with your
kids
i have one son and we have a very close
relationship we've had a very close
relationship throughout the years um
probably when we're growing up and
usually close and more distant now that
he's older and have his own life
um
but he was my vacation buddy we did take
some you know some vacation some cash
vacations of course bring our own
lunches
um budgeted out i mean it was budgeted
his famous question growing up was mom
is it in the budget
is this in the budget um
and so we he's he's grown up to be like
my my buddy so you can so you can live
and you can raise kids and they'll still
like you yeah you can and and to be able
to like say like if we need something we
need tires for the car or an emergency
happens i had a water leak a couple
years ago and to be able to just like
take care of that it's just like
i can't believe it like i'm still in
shock like oh i can just pay for that
and and take care of those emergencies
without stressing without putting it on
a card
you know it's what like and if he needs
something i can provide you know with
within reasonable requests of course
wow
very important very important yeah i
mean you you you have
reaped all the benefits of all the hard
work and you have worked really hard at
this yeah i'm so proud of you thank you
very well done thank you i listen to
your show all the time i have people in
my life that were going through it too
and motivating me and i motivated them
in return sylvia and joe are listening
they're i mentored them they're
listening um
there's just um
friends my friend kim has been my
cheerleader my boyfriend shannon is
listening he's supporting me through
this and it's just been
unreal
[Laughter]
great job
great job all right what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
cash envelopes for sure
um
i have to remember my notes i'm so
nervous uh cash envelopes
um
i just saying
finding ways to reduce your monthly
outgoing income i went through
everything i reduced my cable bill i
reduced my phone bill i eliminated a
bunch of things that i didn't need and i
kept it real simple
and just finding creative ways to
to have fun without buying stuff and
take care of your stuff so they last a
long time you'll have to buy a bunch of
stuff all you know every few years
maintenance is a good idea yes yes
occasionally i get that email it says
remind people to do maintenance on their
car yeah
that's a good thing i like that
good for you well done erica well we got
a copy of the baby steps millionaire's
book comes out january the 11th but
we're going to give you an early edition
copy just to congratulate you because we
think you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire in no time it's the next
chapter for your story after your debt
free scream
and a copy of the total money makeover
for you to give away somebody get them
started on their journey yes you never
know that 10 and a half years later they
may have their house and everything paid
off yes you're a superhero girl thank
you so much for your support thank you
for what you do thank you
powerful very very well done erica
fresno california area 290 000 paid off
house and everything
did it in 10 and a half years
that it making 70 to 90 to 100. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two
one i'm a single mom if i can do it you
can too
i'm debt-free
i like the cheer
so in grad school dave there's always
one student in every class the
curvebuster
yeah that everyone's like this test was
so hard and we should be able to there's
always that one student that just got
100 or 95 and just took all of our
excuses away yeah she just took all your
excuses away everybody
no excuses after that i'm in california
i could never pay off a house wrong i'm
a single mom i could never wrong i've
got kids i could never
i'm looking at it right i'm afraid my
children will be damaged if i work right
wrong
i can't do six days a week i can't do
seven days with yes you can i'm looking
at her right there congratulations
incredible well done and well adjusted
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 8 31
what then shall we say in response to
these things if god is for us
who can be against us
winston churchill said success consists
of going from failure to failure without
loss of enthusiasm
i have been doing that a long time
that makes me feel good about my life
thanks winston
randy's with us in louisiana hi randy
how are you
hey dave pastor hi dr john how are y'all
doing great man what's up
so i have a question pertaining to
babysit 4 that's what i'm currently on
uh
i am putting money into my newly open
roth ira
and i'm wondering should i be doing that
in particular or should i be putting
money aside to
i'll put down down payment for a home
i'm currently in college i'm on my last
year
and i'm wondering which route should i
go
i would just pile up cash i wouldn't be
doing retirement until you graduate
okay gotcha and then you can use that
cash for whatever you need to after you
after you transition into your
uh you know your your career-based job
in whatever city you end up win and all
that kind of stuff
okay you got plenty of time that you got
plenty of time to investing in to buy a
house you know i wouldn't do either of
those today but if you have a big pile
of cash and you get out and you get
moved and you get settled into an
apartment and you get your new job and
the checks start coming in then you go
okay i kind of want to think about
buying a house
and then you start saying i'm going to
move some of that cash over into the
house fund or i want to get my roth ira
started i'm going to move some of it
over to the roth ira fund either one of
those is fine are you dating someone
serious
uh yes i am we're not
that far to our relationship we're doing
extremely well but i'm just
trying to reach my own goals pursue my
financial dreams well i'll just tell you
advice from an old man that hasn't got
anything to do with money if you buy a
house
and then a year later get married you
will discover you bought the wrong house
okay
because she wasn't in on the selection
of it so my point being it's okay to
rent if you're in a serious relationship
and coming out of school
you know if you rent an apartment for a
year you're dating you get engaged you
get married
then we buy and all during that time
you're piling up cash to make the buy
you haven't lost any ground none
you're going to be just fine there's no
law that says you're going to hell if
you don't buy a house by the time you're
23
or something like that i mean so give
yourself a little wiggle room jay is in
battle creek michigan hi jay how are you
hey how you guys doing better than i
deserve how can we help
hey dave so um looks like i just want to
say that my wife and i found you uh
during our when our parish priest was
giving us wedding counseling uh he set
us up with a total money makeover and
since then we have paid off 30 000 in
debt
built up a fully funded emergency fund
and we bought a house with percent down
eight thousand under asking using an elt
i wanna start off by saying that so
thank you wow thank you brother you game
on
how can we help today
now my question is with the new house my
mother-in-law wants to buy us a lot of
gifts for christmas
between
my wife and i know that that she has no
control over her finances she has muscle
credit cards a car loan and she doesn't
even have her own place but we love her
we love her so much but we just don't
know how we can tell her no to the gifts
that she's expecting to buy
um i've even offered to give her i i
told my wife i offered i can give her uh
this little money makeover set her up
with ramsay plus with financial peace
but i just don't how do we tell her no
to the gift i i just feel bad doing that
to her since we just gotta have that
how long you been married
uh we've been there now for just over a
year
is your mother-in-law single
yes she's living with her mom so my
wife's grandma
okay
all right
here's the
hey i want to applaud your spirit and
applaud you've had some a string of some
pretty remarkable success financially
and man
like anybody whose life has been changed
by something positive you want to run
out on the street and
tell everybody and especially those that
you love
the hard reality that you're you're
you're picking up now is you can't
control what she does
and it's there's few things in life
harder than watching people you love
make decisions that are going to hurt
them
if you wanted to you could set up a
boundary and say hey this year we don't
want gifts we want to do this but
dave i mean you're a grandparent i'm not
that that may be more harmful let me
say a communicate a different message to
her than you intend to
um you can give her that gift
uh the total money makeover something
like that
but the idea that a
young guy who's marrying her daughter
who's just come into her life a year ago
is gonna give her this
is going to come be her savior man i
want to relieve you of that brother
that's not your job your job is to love
her the best you can and by the way
you're not going to be very good at that
job yeah
or is they love her the best you can no
i'm the job of fixing her life yeah you
can't do that yeah love her daughter
well how about that yeah so
second thing is this
uh
how's the relationship between your
daughter and her mom
your wife and her mom very good
okay
then you don't need to say boo
you don't need to say a single syllable
not your mother she needs to talk to her
mom
and it would at
most
at most nothing is okay saying nothing's
okay but saying at most hey mom
we're really enjoying debt free
and we've worked really hard to get out
of that and i know you're struggling and
and i appreciate your generous spirit so
much you're such an amazing mom
uh but i gotta tell you it makes us feel
very very weird that you're borrowing
money to give us gifts when we've worked
so hard to get out of debt
and and we wish you would dial it back
and not borrow any money to bless us uh
but you can do what you want to do and
we're going to love you either way
but it just makes us feel weird and i
just wanted you to know that
because i i i i it's it's it takes a
little of the joy off of it because we
know it's not brilliant because it's
bringing harm to you
and that's a that's a mother-daughter
conversation that's not one-year
son-in-law coming in and being like oh
yeah hey lady you know you don't get
what we're saying you're not even in the
room when this happens
and it's not by text and it's not by
phone it's on in person if at all
possible absolutely and it's one time
and then drop it yeah and move on i love
your heart but
yeah you cannot fix her
she's not within your control
and it's again it's it's one of the
things john and i say around here all
the time one of the most painful parts
of adulthood is watching people we love
do stupid things yeah
we can't keep them from doing it yeah
whether it's super destructive things
like addictions
or uh abuse
or whatever all the way to
uh you know simply buying christmas
gifts on a credit card that you wish you
didn't do and i know the irony of this
is that this is an advice show and
that's what advice pays my bills
but
in the real world in relationships and
people's you know we're going to go to
christmas parties this year we're going
to hang out with their in-laws this year
man i've just i've i've burned people
over the course of my life trying to
throw advice into situations that where
it wasn't asked and so i want to be
invited in anymore that's it i have a
rule
i do not give my opinion
until you ask me yes invite me in and if
you ask me i'm obligated going full dave
you asked that's right that's really
true on the show i mean you guys call
them
so we're going to tell you yeah you know
but i don't drive up beside some guy at
the stop light and go hey looks like you
got a lot of payments
[Laughter]
and you say it you just have your
windows up
but the the the number of times i have
gone to someone said well hey you know
uh
wow yeah the only time i intersect the
only time i'm going to intersect into
someone's life uninvited as if i think
they're in danger that's exactly right
or a child's in danger yep and then i'll
put most of you in jail in that case yes
so um yeah you don't want me around in
that situation yeah that's exactly right
if someone's going to hurt themselves
yeah i will call if you start talking to
me about suicide 9-1-1 yep yeah i don't
play with those i am not playing with
this [ __ ] but other than that i'm gonna
wait to be invited in and so here's a
great thing jay this last caller if he
lives his life of
she's gonna want to know she's gonna
want to know yeah maybe maybe but i'll
be honest
hardly any of our relatives do our stuff
okay
it's just full disclosure that's right
all right
a couple of them do but most of them
just think wow they did kind of good
over there at the ramsey blue look
that's like what exactly yeah oh well
that's the way it is you know so uh
yeah well
we know you don't like credit cards but
you know
you got this new co-host john baloney
with you
merry christmas that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace it's kelly
producer and phone screener for the
ramsay show if you would like to do your
debt free scream live on the show make
sure you visit theramsieshow.com and
register we would love for you to come
to nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you